as ukraine's president vladimir silensky
was broadcasting news of successful
counter-attacks in the donbass a series
of powerful explosions shook ukraine's
capital kyiv overnight
smoke billowed over the city whose mayor
vitali klitschko confirmed that the
first attacks on the city in weeks had
indeed taken place
klitschko said missiles had hit
unspecified infrastructure targets but
caused no deaths the attack comes just
as life in kiev had begun to resemble a
kind of normality after russia decided
to concentrate its forces in the east
okay let's go straight to dw
correspondent young philip schultz who's
standing by for us in kiev jan phillip
what can you tell us about the
explosions heard in kiev early this
morning
we were woken up by air rage alerts in
the early morning hours and from what we
know right now there have been some
explosions in two districts in the
eastern and north eastern part of kiev
several eyewitnesses say that they have
they saw smoke rising there and
kiev's mayor vitaly klitschko said that
services are already operating on the
ground
we don't know yet what has been hit
exactly but there is at least one person
injured and treated in a hospital
according to local officials
jan phillip i'll get you to stay with us
we'll come back to you in a moment first
let's
take a look at the eastern city of
seville donetsk ukraine says it has
recaptured parts of the city from
russian forces ukrainian troops have
been battling to hang on there their
last stronghold in the region of luhansk
for days russian firepower has been
concentrated in donbass
[Music]
local officials say ukrainian forces are
putting up a fierce fight though claims
from both sides are difficult to verify
in an interview the governor of the
luhansk region says russia is suffering
significant losses
the reason russians are blowing up
bridges is to stop our reinforcements in
saviro donetsk our guys are defending
the whole luhansk region and the
russians are afraid our defenders will
stay successful
according to information from ukraine
russia has been pushed back from moving
into territory west of sievro donetsk
striking a blow to russian efforts to
claim the entire donbass region
for its part russia says its military
has managed several successful attacks
this footage is from the russian defense
ministry and the location cannot be
verified
but russia says its forces shot down a
ukrainian plane carrying weapons and
munitions near the black sea port of
odessa
the ministry says russian missiles also
struck an artillery training center in
the sumi region where foreign
instructors worked
in the capital kiev the u.s ambassador
to ukraine promised america will assist
with investigations into thousands of
war crimes allegations against the
russian army
i think the efforts of the prosecutor
general are really important and i do
not think they should stop or be paused
just because the war continues i think
people deserve justice and they deserve
justice now
after more than three months of war
people who have held out for this long
are still looking to leave
the evacuations and the deep sense of
separation and loss that come with them
are a daily reality
young philip schultz is still with us in
kiev young philip ukraine is claiming it
has recaptured large parts of sivero
what's the significance of that
development and can it be verified at
this point
we can't verify
if they really recaptured the majority
of severo donetsk but we can verify
that they have pushed back russian
forces in many parts of the city but
the russians are still fighting with
heavy weapons in the region and they are
putting all their strengths into
recapturing
or into capturing the city i should say
it's a highly important city it's an
administrative
hub in the region and it also has some
important chemical industry but most
importantly
it's part of this small pocket of the
luhansk part of the donbass region that
is still at least partly under ukrainian
control
and as those battles wage supply lines
in the east are becoming critical to
both russia and ukraine do you know
which side is having more trouble
perhaps now replenishing troops and
weapons in the area
well for the ukrainian side the biggest
challenge at the moment is
that the promised heavy weapons from
abroad
will arrive but all observers say this
will probably still take
some weeks until they are ready to use
in the donbass region the ukrainians
also have to deal with
heavy losses among their soldiers in in
the region
on the other hand the russians as you
know they had
severe problems with their supply lines
in the first weeks of the war but this
problem for them has
significantly reduced in the donbass
region in recent weeks they can use a
combination of heavy artillery missile
strikes and and air
air raids and
so
they they make advances but the advances
are still much slower than many people
predicted some weeks ago
dw correspondent young philip schultz
and kiev thanks so much
let's cross to kiera rudick a member of
the ukrainian parliament and a leader of
the political party goros who is
currently in dublin curie riddick
it's now been more than a hundred days
since russia invaded ukraine i'm curious
given the fact that at least at the
moment there's no end in sight how are
you personally coping and what do you
hear from other ukrainians
hello thank you so much for having me
well we do understand that there needs
to be a switch from the sprint
to the marathon and we are ready to this
marathon
we do understand that it will be tough
we also do understand that we will have
to
gather our own resilience and old
results and to make sure that we push
them back this is why i'm traveling
right now and this is why i'm uh calling
for every single leader of every single
country to give us what is necessary to
give us the weapons to give us the money
to give us their supplies so we can make
this final push to push russians back
because while we have the support of our
allies while we have the result of our
people i'm very sure that we can win
this war
you talk about uh
the international community coming
together for these weapons germany and
other western countries have promised
ukraine more advanced weapons with
intense fighting going on in the dumbass
are you concerned about whether they
will reach ukrainian troops on time
yes i'm concerned about that because
it's only now when we started receiving
the weapons and supplies that we were
promised like two to three months ago
the logistics is complicated it's not
amazon prime we do understand that but
we also understand that uh our lives are
working on the logistics faster and we
do understand that they are
trying to get it to us in time so what
we can do from our side is to make sure
that logistics within ukraine is working
properly and that uh
once the weapons are crossing the border
we deliver it to the front as soon as
possible
as you well know there have now been six
sanctions packages directed against
russia this week the eu agreed on the
latest a ban on most oil imports is this
enough in your
view no this is not enough well first of
all these sanctions are half measure
so they you allowed hungary to push them
back and allow partially their oil to be
uh
to be still used secondly they will only
start working six months from now so my
people will have to stand still and
fight for six months before they
actually start working because before
european countries will stop paying a
billion dollars a day for russian oil
understood um that is akira rudeck a
member of ukrainian parliament and a
leader of the political party golos many
many thanks